our top Fonterra president refusing to
be politically correct
while our national security is at stake
you heard him refer to the Manhattan
truck terrorist suspect as an animal
yesterday threatening to throw him in
Gitmo now he's calling for an even
tougher punishment for the slaughter of
eight deaths this morning tweeting we'd
love to send the NYC terrorist to
Guantanamo but statistically that
process takes much longer than going
through the federal system there was
also something appropriate about keeping
him in the home of the horrible crime he
committed should move fast death penalty
this afternoon we heard more from
President Trump on the flawed
immigration program that allowed the
jihadi suspect into our country I'm
calling on Congress to immediately
terminate the diversity visa lottery
program it's a disaster for our country
the people put in that lottery are not
that country's finest we know that the
program presents significant
vulnerabilities to our national security
we want a system ultimately that's
merit-based so we can bring in people
that will help our country grow our
country and be safe for our country
all right so many people on the lek left
Gregg are saying that because the
president is weighing in on these
criminal proceedings he's jeopardizing a
conviction mm-hmm I don't know about
that because this has never happened
before this is the first and this is a
guy who's not a politician for seventy
years of his life who speaks his mind
and he's got this little technology that
allows him to do it you it shows that
you could put the citizen in the White
House but you can't take him out of the
way he's still a citizen and his
ill-advised as it might be he's
reflecting the frustrations in the anger
of his constituents he's acting exactly
like we would and also the reason why
he's saying this is because he views
this person not as a typical criminal he
views this person as an enemy combatant
right if somebody said you shouldn't be
saying that about Nazi war criminals you
know screw that they're Nazi war
criminals that's how he sees these guys
as enemy combatants so the rules of
comport
don't apply in this situation he should
not have to worry about what he says
about an enemy combatant it should not
matter the other thing too was this guy
apparently you know he wants an Isis
flag in his room and I'm thinking we
should give it to him but we should dip
it in bacon fat and then put it right up
there okay that's why again who does
that offend it's an Isis flag I mean I
don't understand why we have these rules
of comportment about certain people and
things okay
provocative got felt it's not
provocative it's the ISIS flag that's
right the Guantanamo issue President
Trump is bringing that back up do you
think that he's just trying to kind of
flip over everything President Obama did
or didn't do with a rock I think he was
speaking based on his instinct which is
to say like this guy should have to face
really tough punishment but the thing is
that while that is an instinct for a
citizen to believe for a
commander-in-chief then it's more
difficult because you are the chief law
enforcement officer and the Supreme
Court has already ruled many many times
especially with the Hamdi decision in
2007 which was a disappointment to the
administration that we couldn't try him
as an enemy combatant because he had
habeas corpus rights the court is going
to give he's a legal permanent resident
so it wasn't gonna fly in the court and
that's what would have taken so long I
understand the instinct but I think that
also sending him to Gitmo would make him
a martyr to Isis I mean better to leave
him here and New York City has a
near-perfect prosecution record for
terrorism cases and the evidence against
this guy is so overwhelming is the death
penalty situation I guess they have to
just yes I think my New York's New York
sit in New York State I think do you
have a death penalty I don't think so no
I think that the president's saying he's
got the death penalty that is reflecting
what a lot of American citizens would
feel about him which is legally I don't
necessarily think that that will fly
because of how they try him but I think
it was better for him to be tried in
America and also he's going to be tried
in America
talking about Gitmo is useless on this
particular case I would if he captures
enemy combatants on the battlefield take
them to get Moe I see no problem with
that I think it's a perfectly reasonable
place to put terrorists one do you have
a problem with any way that President
Trump comported himself after the attack
well I really have trouble with the idea
that he said that our justice system is
a laughingstock a joke to the world and
I think though I think our justice
system is the envy of the world and I
mean so you know I was listening to Greg
and I think just like Dana said you know
Greg's right you know it's looks like
one of us is in the White House and
somebody says oh you know there's a
threat to the herd and we say go get
them to the shepherd go get him we we
don't like that mean old wolf and in
this case that's what trump is behaving
like he's not behaving as Dana said like
the commander in chief like the leader
of the flock who would in some ways say
here are our rules here's how we have
survived as a nation a constitutional
based republic for so long is because
we're a nation of laws and we understand
how despicable this character is but
guess what we have a system that can
handle it and put it in place
instead he derives our own justice
system it's unbelievable that speak to
the wolves they're not listening you
have to kill the world but you're
speaking to us as the American people we
care about what plays and rules that
wouldn't apply to wolves it was a
president Trump's point though I think
giving him the death penalty makes him a
martyr this is what he wants he wanted
to die he wanted to die by suicide by
cop which is why he had those two bogus
guns she was hoping to die he wants to
be a martyr I'm actually with Senator
Lindsey Graham on this who's a military
lawyer for 33 years that thinks we
should try them as an enemy combatant
and send her to some place like Gitmo I
guarantee if you polled the detainees at
Gitmo they would rather die than be
there so I think we actually give this
guy what he wants if he gets the death
penalty and I think there's an argument
to be made that we are at war with Isis
this guy is a terrorist
he took up arms with Isis against the
United States and he's an enemy
combatant it should be treated as such
put him in Rikers Island I don't think
he's a legal permanent resident there's
a reason that we didn't bring all of
those Gitmo people remember President
Obama wanted to bring all the Gitmo
detainees to New York City for trial and
Erica said absolutely not because as
soon as they get here they get habeas
corpus rights and that and they were not
legal permanent residents and they
didn't deserve it
well we've also seen people like senator
Cruz which I fully support in stripping
the rights of US citizenship from
individuals that choose to join Isis so
I think that is something particularly
in the wake of this that Congress
absolutely needs to revisit and
something that we need to do as a
country these guys are not what soon as
you join Isis you were no longer an
American you were no longer a permanent
resident the United States and you
deserve to rot in jail the question that
Lisa is how do you prove it because you
think back there was an interesting
piece in The Wall Street Journal
editorial this morning defending the
diversity program the President Trump is
so critical of that diversity visa
program and in the piece The Journal
editorial writers talked about how the
Sonia tsarnayev brothers the ones who
did the Boston bombing the one the
younger brother they were really
transitioned into Isis followers as
children so they were here and then they
radicalized while in the US or Omar
mattina Orlando club bomber
he was an american-born citizen
scientist and Bernadino guy u.s. born
his wife was the immigrant so the
question is you know how do you revoke
someone pledged their allegiance to Isis
and I think when you do that you with
the legislation my understanding of the
legislation that senator Cruz put
forward I think it's if you go and
physically join Isis you want them they
also think that it's shade on it should
also apply to people here in the United
States if you pledge an allegiance to
Isis if you take up arms against United
States in the name of Isis as evidenced
by what this guy shouted when he got out
of the car we know by the note that he
he left he is a member of Isis that is
what drove him to do that that in his
radical extremist ideology then you
should no longer be considered to United
States citizens agree with me I don't
believe the president was saying the
entire US justice system is a
laughingstock I think he was referring
to the lack of speed with which
criminals can get prosecuted because
they can drag everything out on appeal
now let's listen to what Senate what
sessions said the Attorney General about
this go terrorists should know this this
administration will use
lawful tools at our disposal including
prosecution in article three courts or
at Guantanamo Bay if anyone has any
doubt about it they can ask the more
than 500 criminals whom the Department
of Justice has convicted of terrorism
related offenses since 9/11 and they can
ask the dozens of enemy combatants at
Guantanamo so good for what would you do
with this guy well first of all just
about the diversity visa one is correct
is that that's not gonna stop the got
people that are already here but
diversity without merit is Russian
Roulette so we have to change it for the
future it may not work now in the past
what I would do is the piece of
information here he's married with three
kids so here's a fiend with the family
and I said this before yesterday and
Terry Schappert has brought this up and
people are he's not really a lone wolf
if you've got family so if the families
do it you if you say your family is
going to suffer we're sending your
family back if you do this that directly
affects the community in which these
suspects the people that you have
suspicions on live and it forces people
forces family members to say well what
he is doing is directly affecting our
lives so if people know if maybe if a
person knows that their family is at
risk then they might not do it or maybe
the family might act on it so here's the
thing though the in fact for what I read
was that the wife was taken away today
from their Patterson New Jersey home
with the kids with the luggage and
everything we don't know what happened
but she was interviewed first by the FBI
and apparently according to the reports
said that she knew nothing of this okay
so then I never do well I don't know but
I'm just saying what the report was so
now I'm listening to you and I'm
thinking to myself you know in our
tradition we don't say that the four
sins of the father should be visited on
the child mhm and when you have a
situation like that I think it was jason
chaffetz who said to us yesterday in
israel this is what happens if you have
this problem you know they they they
raised the Palestinian house and the
family right but we don't do that we
don't say if somebody committed a
terrible crime here in the United States
this is different this is war this is
not a crime anymore this is actually war
which is different than just a crime
where we take a criminals family that
would
absurd we would not do that to an armed
robber take his family but this is war
and in war you have to change the rules
in the rules serious nothing's really
working and preventing these things
except like we don't know something to
be prevented because it's behind the
scenes in this case a tool which is
targeting the family and saying this
family we're not hurting the family but
you're leaving you're all going that
isn't that something new parent it's a
deterrent and it could work you know how
much did this wife really about hair for
his family he was willing to die the
other day when he came out with fake
weapons who knows Trump got into a lot
of trouble when he said you know you
have to go after the family members you
have to go after the wives now it looks
like you know that might be in play
legally or otherwise well I don't know
how how in play I mean is there
legislation that it's going to be
introduced or the executive order in
play because at every moment it turns
out the wife had no idea the brother had
no idea the father had no idea I did I
did I do think to the whim when it comes
to especially the women and how they are
treated by these men that is possible
she had no idea she might have had no
rights might not had ability to do
anything or know anything or to work the
one thing that I think is very curious
I'm not gonna get to this in the B block
is just how many people in the community
had actually seen him practicing this
for a couple of weeks that's a fairly so
if they know that there was some kind of
consequence maybe a community member
would would see something and say
something novel idea